foreign
[Music]
since Michael Myers vanished Without a
Trace
[Music]
I'll
[Music]
I was certain but I saw him
watching me
you pretend like you moved on but you're
actually just obsessed with death what
are you gonna do when Michael comes back
for you because he is coming
but this time
something feels different
he's more dangerous
[Music]
he killed my daughter but tonight I will
kill him come and get me
[Music]
maybe the only way he can die is if I
die too it all ends now
[Music]
you came here to kill me so do it
[Music]
there's a lover in the story but the
story is still the same there's a
lullaby for suffering and a paradox to
blame I didn't know I had permission
[Music]
you want it darker
we kill the flame
you don't think I'm a bad person
you look like the kind that's convinced
himself he's got this under his thumb
I'm ready
magnified Sanctified be the Holy Name
vilified crucified in the human frame
you want it darker
we kill the flame
[Music]
many love will set you free
middle child two brothers were actually
very close but they live in different
states only child childhood obsessions
Christmas magic
my name is Michael you're a great dancer
you're a terrible liar and that's kid
I've always imagined that my life was
like a typical romantic comedy you were
so confident and you just ripped off
your clothes like your strippered a
bachelorette party and I basically
shower with clothes on
don't just shut up now shall we go to
your place tonight there's my door
before we go in just open the door okay
what is this Michael oh you don't want
to oh my God they're in here too
I think you're very cool and I'm worried
that you're going to break my heart you
know mad this is my friend Mike a friend
yes Mom just a friend what is going on
here who is this guy he's my boyfriend
your boyfriend I think it's a great kid
we may not look like it but we are
actually kind of hip oh my God we were
gonna go to Woodstock you know
well I am let's just take a moment to
appreciate this beauty
get what is going on are you all right
come down off the ledge Mike I'm seeing
a doctor tomorrow
I'm afraid the news isn't good
I was always afraid kit would break my
heart and eventually he did he broke it
open
yeah
you have to run the race in front of you
because that's all there is look back
this is less of a rom-com and more of a
love story you can't sit for four hours
with promised bed all the beds are
occupied give my husband your bed well
that was Oscar worthy word for Shirley
McLean
I'm sorry I never told you how good your
ass looks in your khaki pants I was
afraid if you understood how beautiful
you are if you'd leave me thank you for
inviting us it was Kit's idea I was
vehemently opposed to it
and like all love stories it never
actually ends
[Music]
my name is Dr Rose Carter what do you
want from me
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it is dead in your life
I've seen it
[Music]
you
do you have it
[Music]
it's smiling at me Carl
[Music]
but not a friendly smile
the worst smile I've ever seen
I am not gonna keep running
[Music]
I have to face it
doesn't smile only in theater in special
previews Thursday at 7 pm get tickets
now
[Music]
oh we're gonna sing along yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
why are you here
suppose I'm here to make friends with
you
and your Dad's too
but my heart is broken why is it broken
because of what I have to do today
[Music]
crazy woman
you see the four of us have a very
important job to do
in fact it might be the most important
job
history of the world
we were called
and are united by a common vision
which has now become a command
and we cannot ignore
[Music]
the four of us are here
to prevent the Apocalypse
your family hasn't chosen to make a
horrible decision
have you fail to choose
the world went
the greatest love story ever told Romeo
sweet Juliet was missing a chapter
mine son of them no get up you lazy cow
I have cholera you do not have cholera
you don't understand they were being all
gross and he was saying things to her
that he just said to me three days ago
yes three nurse
so you're gonna break them up of course
I am Romeo and Juliet doesn't even sound
right you want my help with this we just
need to stop a wedding my boyfriend is
about to make the biggest mistake of his
life hang on a second it's your
boyfriend's wedding
ouch
blow me
Roslyn I met a boy let me guess Romeo
Montague isn't it everybody knows Romeo
Montague but Juliet if I settle down
with just one man when you can sample at
the buffet of Life who wants to buy us
some drinks
[Music]
there's a difference
[Music]
I just wonder if all this drama
is adding to the attraction I'm going to
fake my own death I'll drink this potion
it'll look like I'm dead that is quite
possibly the dumbest thing I've ever
heard in my life
drink it already
foreign
[Music]
doing in our front yard our entire world
is in grave danger I want you to come
with me on an expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when you went
missing but now
you're all we got
Mr Clay I'm a huge fan thank you I'm
your dad do you think you could Forge
his autograph
where in the world are we
[Music]
brought the dog sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
[Music]
[Applause]
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you
dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa what is
this place the cliffs are alive and the
waters dissolve the flesh off your bones
everything down here is trying to kill
us
[Music]
foreign
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
I was too
I'm loving this family reunion but come
on we got a world to save
[Music]
I need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
didn't see that coming
[Music]
[Music]
over
[Music]
thank you
I wanted to stop
my channel
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
beautiful isn't it
it's really nice
you can hold it
what is it it's a puzzle
[Applause]
and it's almost finished
keep going
so if I solve it
do I get a prize
I do
foreign
[Music]
six configurations
it opens up
and it cuts you
[Applause]
then they come to collect
oh
it's time
greater Delights await we wish to see
you proceed
their blood their pain
all for us
that you pray for
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
this is my family happy birthday Pop oh
cool look there's another gift they open
it you you open you open it on the count
of three okay one
two three boom God
you see I'm funny
welcome it's dangerous game
immersive murder mystery where you are
the detective
solve the mystery
find the Killer
and win the game it sounds like a hoot
let's let's play how about it
I'm out of here enjoy your creepy board
game
don't be alone join us in the great room
the Killer is on the loose solve the
puzzles to send them home to win the
game
only one shall remain we need to get out
of here Mom's right is this your idea of
a joke I didn't do it no you didn't
you're a [ __ ] no I've heard of
immersive games but they're usually fun
you must play the game Malik consider
this rewarding
there are consequences
open the door
if you're here then you already know who
she is
Lydia tar is many things
inductor tar began her career with the
Cleveland Orchestra Chicago Symphony
Orchestra the Boston Symphony Orchestra
until she had last arrived here at our
own New York Philharmonic in 2013 Berlin
elected tar as its principal conductor
and she's remained there ever since
Lydia tar is also written music the
stage and Screen she is one of only 15
egots meaning those who have won all
four major entertainment Awards thank
you for joining us my stroke thank you
[Applause]
how's the writing going
[Music]
so well
hearing something
something schopenhauer measured a man's
intelligence against his sensitivity to
noise
do you ever find yourself overwhelmed by
emotion
yes that does happen
foreign
I received another weird email
there's no reason to get caught up in
any intrigue
I'm worried
starting to disappear into herself
if you want to dance the mask you must
service the composer you've got to
supplement yourself your ego and yes
your identity
in fact stand in front of the public and
garden
and obliterate yourself
[Music]
where are you from I'm an American
journalist I came here as a special
correspondent and what about you I'm
here relax
we have 45 minutes till the bar closes
long enough to get swacked
[Music]
meet again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean we're on a charitable course
please don't go into detail
[Music]
who's that friend of yours what I do
interesting
he's waiting for you outside of the
hotel right now
this country is kind of like a gambler's
paradise and everybody's giving the odds
a shake whichever game they feel like
playing your British friend interests me
how long have you known him how do you
know he is who he says he is I could
just snap my fingers and envelope of
twenty thousand dollars in your lap like
that
[Music]
quick dreams
did you know the Department of Defense
is after you
know how many people are playing in your
game a lot of people are involved
[Music]
things aren't as simple here as you want
to think
[Music]
you're gonna get us both killed
him what are you Moses
I wanted to know the exact dimensions of
Hell
so many dreams
we share like the stars
coveted rooms
[Music]
I call upon the spirits of this house
to grant us a moment of your time
[Music]
gave her father
take my hands it might help
but she dare touch me old [ __ ]
Tara I killed you once I'll kill you
again
[Music]
in the Gordon family curse let's just
start with seeing Dr Sanchez tomorrow
I'm not crazy
mid teens is when this disease first
manifests and you can be prone to fits
of anger stop going in my room and
violence
experience multiple personalities
use different voices hear voices
you okay
I do think it's interesting
you don't know anything about that I'm
not gonna let anyone hurt you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
best
I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning Anne but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
[Music]
Natalie's parents believe that she is
being possessed by some sort of evil
entity
she's not as scary as she looks she can
hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we gotta stick together in this place
[ __ ]
we have a female student in the class
only as an observer because as you know
women are strictly forbidden from
performing exorcism female surgeons are
once Unthinkable somebody had to be the
first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
strike Terror lured into the Beast now
defiling this innocent child
I can't hear you no
[Music]
really I'm here
with
you
yes
you have a gift I'd like to teach you
this relationship it's personal we all
have a personal relationship with God
and she's gone
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
staff sergeant Barnes you and the
members of your unit are hereby found
guilty of all the charges brought
against you
what the hell is this all about right
and wrong good evil peorial
it makes my heart when I hear about
missing children people never recover
trying to tell me you want me to kill
people for you no
just a minute times
can I help you I want to know how you've
been selling underage content for so
long without so much as a warrant for
your arrest
and what's your daughter's name again oh
Betty Betty Betty Hartley
we're not criminals we're sanitation
workers taking out the traps
I don't want anything from you this is
for what you do to little kids
I'm FBI special agent Reynolds this is
my partner special agent Kensington we
have a few questions we'd like to ask
you you're just paranoid them
asking the [ __ ] questions all of them
Mr Ambrose do I have your attention
thank you for your continued service
Sergeant Barnes
[Music]
[Music]